est-ce que ça se peut d'avoir des poils
sur la langue la vérité c'est que ok
cette maladie elle s'appelle la maladie
de la langue poilue ou la maladie de la
langue velue mais qu'en fait c'est pas
vraiment des poils les poils qui
apparaissent sur la langue dans ces
cas-là ils sont noirs en général mais
parfois ils peuvent aussi avoir une
autre couleur genre bleu rouge jaune ou
même vert bon mais alors vu que c'est
pas vraiment des poils qu'est-ce que
c'est et ben notre langue normalement
elle se nettoie toute seule et sa
muqueuse se renouvelle un peu comme
toutes nos cellules sauf que parfois
pour des raisons que là encore on
connaît pas toujours très bien et ben ça
foire il y a bien des nouvelles cellules
qui se créent mais les anciennes elles
s'en vont pas donc il y a de la kératine
qui s'accumule sur nos papilles ces
petits trucs là en relief qu'on a sur la
langue et qui nous permettent par
exemple de sentir le goût de ce qu'on
mange du coup tout ça toutes ces
cellules elles s'entassent elles
s'entassent les unes sur les autres et
ça finit par donner des petits filaments
qui ressemble à des poils et ça prend
des couleurs différentes en fonction de
tout ce qu'il y a autour comme bactéries
et compagnie alors c'est sûrement pas
ouf à vivre comme expérience mais ça
soigne ça se